[Music]
hello welcome to another exciting
episode what's in the box man I'm milli
vanilli guess what no knives this week
they took the knives away from his max
he pokes someone in the hallway dick so
instead this week it's a liftoff
lift it off sir just like an old
astronaut sir these are all bond
replicas from the good folks at factory
entertainment based on the actual film
props from the Eon Productions archives
best presentation of anything that's
ever been in the box James Bond
baby double O 6 that's to go underwater
it's one of those mouthpieces you go
what's a rebreather must you touch
everything still work this symbol and
anybody worth their salt knows belongs
to what Spectre James Bond
double-oh-seven authentic Spectre ring
as featured in From Russia With Love oh
it's a display yes you could put this
[ __ ] on a shelf as you know this
is the biggest [ __ ] magnet on the
planet any [ __ ] woman or man walks
into your room seeing this on your shelf
they're like I'm getting laughs I'm
totally like here comes the worst sex
I've ever had
that's an octopus you know what my mom
would say a sharp tiger that's what my
mom used to sell me when I put on a tie
I went to church a sharp tiger
that's what I'd [ __ ] said anybody you
put it in here and then it resembled the
Sun baby like will you marry me for your
sake I hope so
you think stormtroopers getting married
was sad [ __ ] wait until a Bond
villain marries and who you marry in
that instance if you're dressing up as
Blofeld at that wedding
duuude woman dress up like the cat and
there's no stroker the whole time she's
wearing white the whole point is um I
started mocking it but like I'm gonna
call these [ __ ] up and be like you
know what's next
weddings mm-hmm absolutely stupid
you're a ring guy no I think it's it's
all right but it's bulky does he do
anything with it does it work as a like
you can use this as a rubber stamp or it
flips open and there's a little bit of
dust above the pharmacy
yes it's pretty impressive though if
you're into the world of James Bond why
would you want to wear the villains ring
well cause they can play so I can be
like I'm Bond and you're like I'm the
villain oh my god like out of the mouths
of babes other vermin that is
absolutely correct [ __ ] response so
you can play mm-hmm all that you say
could be true
what would you pay for that is it real
gold you really have to [ __ ] size the
table you want your jeweler's loupe and
real gold-plated an 18 karat gold with a
genuine black onyx semi-precious stone
only 750 were made worldwide that's how
we're gonna get him 199 oh my god we
were so almost there $200 on them $200
they had a product soft good they're
like we in hiding it with a 99 hundreds
tracking devices James Bond oh seven
limited edition prop replica number 261
500 also by Factory is a nice little
transmitting device you prime it by
pressing that back like this button so
wait I'll let you [ __ ] arm that I
[ __ ] around Allah oh come on the
smaller model it fitted into the heel of
your shoe it's larger brother is
magnetic oh my goodness we gotta take
this on a plate look at this yeah right
oh my god that wouldn't make your seat
mate on a flight nervous at all if you
were just sitting next to somebody
you're sitting next to me on a [ __ ]
plane and I just whip this out and
you're looking at me and I go but I'm
like oh no it's just from the good folks
at factory it's a hell of a replica
larger devices designed for vehicles
while the smaller device can be slipped
on a person Oh
so the good folks in factor not only
built something that looks like it did
in the 60s movie it operates like it
does and and works in a 60s movie man
good what would you pay for that $1.99
they'd laugh you out of the James Bond
Stewart all right 349 close 379 man nah
but again look at that case look at
everything about the presentation this
according to the plaque you hold on oh
yeah yeah oh it's heavy heavy golden eye
lens and keys man this is a CD yes no
that's how old what goldeneye is doing
the internal cd-rom within the central
lens was part of the weapons security
protocol in the film that's how far back
this movie goes back when they were like
James Bond is fighting a compact disc do
something there's a button here Russ I
don't see it they lit up Oh turn it
press them over there I see I see the
side
and these are the keys man they stick in
three two one they both have to do it at
the same time that's just like [ __ ]
work man sir it'll suck turn your case
turn your keys
turn your keys michael madsen in a
[ __ ] in a missile silo telling you to
[ __ ] turn your key he's gonna shoot
you in a [ __ ] head to begin World War
3 what's more terrifying than that if
you're in a Goldeneye you [ __ ] you
pay anything for this like you're like
my parents met watching Goldeneye or I
got my first hand job watching Goldeneye
and the key looks like my mom's many
vibrations
why would that have any - yeah other
than like it disturbs know this has to
have a positive memory attached to it
like oh it's good I think for that piece
yes we're looking at 2:49 really yeah
keep going
no oh they're gonna make you pay through
the nose for liking for these popular
[ __ ] James Bond movies 4:49 still
ridiculously high the rebreathers gonna
be breathin or being available you could
use this device clever these are based
on the breather scene in two different
movies 1965 Thunderball and 2002's die
another day
the modern version he's just to add a
mouthpiece Sean Connery never once said
give me a mouthpiece he's all man by the
time he got to Brosnan [ __ ] Remington
Steele himself needed a mouthpiece his
precious little goes
you ain't no James Bond and you and I
have something incoming I think it's
pretty dope but I thought it was Batman
when I first saw it that's like there's
something Batman pulls out see this at
least looks more like a rebreather cuz
this has the appearance of like a those
look like little aqua to scuba tubes but
the idea of a rebreather makes no sense
whatsoever they don't work in real life
right business this thing as a [ __ ]
rebreather he let it sit for at least a
minute right there there's some air in
there because I think there's about s
seconds were there oh god there's not
like I understand how the technology
works they busted the [ __ ] out and
[ __ ]
that Star Wars movie - man oh when they
went to Greece he charged our banks and
stuff there was a yes Phantom Menace all
the sudden they were like let's pull out
our Jedi rebreathers like it was a
[ __ ] Batman episode this is pretty
damn impressive man I'm really [ __ ]
that Alex Coe this is the old one yes I
thought this is I like this one looks
better with the gold and the little
spinny jammy
mm-hmm spinny Jamie included what would
you pet it for both of the
they come as a set so you're buying both
I would say that is a good 279 you have
to keep going I'd ask you to pay a
little bit more 49 they'd say what are
you [ __ ] high we can cut that price
to three hundred dollars and 22 cents
valued guests 319 bucks
all right g20 it's the laser rifle for
Moonraker I should have [ __ ] guessed
this this kind of badass if you're in
the moon record so it's not like you're
getting your tag for like that doesn't
look like a real gun it doesn't look
like a real gun in the real movie
it's from the Jax enterprise corporation
man okay so it's got the insignia of Sir
Hugo Drax the original weapon
purposefully did not have a trigger so
actors could handle it easily in their
space suit not a single click or trigger
just you know no not at all and this
doesn't even fall down I thought this
was like a sight punch there's no that
either don't even don't can't add to it
as you look back the sound effects not
included kids you got to bring that
yourself
I remember seeing this with my parents
once I've got [ __ ] awkward the end of
the movie he's [ __ ] in space and like
I'm like no I'm like they show entry he
did but it's definitely more implied
than it was comfortable for me a
Catholic kid sit next my Catholic
parents going like what is sex like God
what's bun doing
I think he's attempting reentry and they
have to explain it there in the movie
theater during Moonraker of all places
ma man was so shame that day why would
you pay for this [ __ ] rate I
would say this gun is a $4.99 job away
lower what do you [ __ ] crazy why was
that no trigger well there's a logic
behind logic damn no trigger means I
paying a dime over nine he did it ladies
and gentlemen
[ __ ] yeah you get to keep the [ __ ]
moon records on anything else
this is one more fun thing supposed to
play from the world of James Bond and
stuff
take out your knife dude and do what
James Bond would do cut this [ __ ]
throat and then make love to his widow
oh you are James Bond here look at this
this is a spy snake cam okay you could
shoot a whole movie on that dude
there's my brand new feature Kevin
Smith's brand new movie expected to be
critically reviled is Jason Mewes in spy
cam all right act [ __ ] stooge to the
Nuge here's my spy hold on there is the
bad guy and cut come on it's like a
modern day clerks crazy well done well
done
look at this I hear you now I hear you
trying to talk sex well this is an
outdated notion of what spies do in the
field I believe yes spy watch I see a
little light here or laser oh it's got a
decoder screen this little red thing but
really dude it's a it's literally a
watch does it do anything it tells the
time night scope so you can see in the
night vision oh look at that [ __ ] son
look ready for this okay hey spy school
oh no I'm saying yes Robin I go this is
the Nikon all right do they work I have
two pieces here I could see you and your
eyeballs like right here I feel like I'm
touching it I think between the two of
us man we're getting far too close a
look at one site with crosshairs
retractable this is like Deadshot's gear
bro really what amazing I'll kick your
ass son I'm gonna get you it's my night
vision to charge lasers
I would be on the other roof going he's
doing it wrong oh he's a bad spy this is
my favorite of all this crime tape what
would you pay for this stuff the night
goggles what would you pay for the night
night goggles I would say $14.99 holy
[ __ ]
ding ding ding ding ding ding what would
you pay for the night scope would not be
those $9.99 you're this is scary you did
you look at the cards no I actually
bought these things why you [ __ ] know
yeah dude why would you buy this [ __ ]
you know I was like a year ago I saw it
I was like oh wow it could be have you
ever [ __ ] use this to shoot me taking
a [ __ ] no you're a [ __ ] jerk I'll
tell you that right banking now at your
fleshlight that's fine yes mixed bag
today mixed bag if you're big James Bond
fan holy [ __ ]
lotta eye candy yes if your would be
James Bond yourself
we've just exposed you to world of
bathroom espionage yes I hear that
little camera is gonna create so many
fights in your family dad Jason is
shooting me under the bathroom door
leave your sister alone Jason it's
unnatural but I speech woody there it is
folks
aah what was in the box this week this
cool stuff man
you want to see his pole other stuff out
of the box just let us know right to the
screen junkies right here manager just
below us mentor hit us on the Facebook
page Twitter social media all over man
snapchat us Instagram us all those
things man we're ready for your social
diseases until next time I've been Kevin
Smith Jason you guess what was in the
box but James Bond crap and licensed by
gear
you
you